so I was asked on Twitter to calculate
the number of sarskov-2 particles that
the particles that cause covid-19 how
many there were in the world and so I
did the calculation and it turns out
that there are few enough to fit inside
a regular can of Coke in in all the
world in the whole world in the whole
world you can fit it inside a single can
of Coke so I did a it's a rough back of
the envelope calculation so I'm open to
people disagreeing and saying well it's
way more than that or it's way fewer but
this sort of estimation is called a
Fermi estimate it's named after this
physicist and Rico Fermi who did loads
of these sorts of calculations he was
interested in estimating things his most
famous one was probably when he
calculated the energy released by an
atom bomb that was detonated at the
Trinity nuclear test and he did this by
holding a piece of paper and dropping it
during the blast and calculating how far
the piece of paper moved and then he
used all sorts of physics to try and
calculate that there was about 10
kilotons of TNT equivalent energy
released during this atomic bomb and
actually they're calculated later using
much more accurate calculations it was
around 21 kilotons so it was pretty
close and you know well within an order
of magnitude so that's what these sorts
of calculations are all about so you've
got to start by thinking about how many
particles there are in the world at any
one time and then once you've figured
that out you need to know how big they
are the first part of the calculation
means calculating how many people in the
world are infected at any one time point
and then also calculating how many virus
particles those people have in their
body at any one time so in terms of
calculating the the total number of
people in the world that have got
covid-19 at any one time point there are
various estimates I use a website called
our world in data they estimate that
around half a million people in the
world are infected newly infected each
day with covert 19. and so that is
clearly going to be an underestimate and
the reason for that is that firstly
loads of countries are not going to be
testing everyone they're not going to be
testing as much as countries like the UK
or the US are testing but also we think
that about a third of people that get
covid-19 are asymptomatic so they don't
even know they've got it so they don't
even know to go and get a test so in
order to figure out how many people are
actually infected every day you need to
do a bit of modeling we've got
statistical modeling so there's a group
called The ihme The Institute for health
metrics and evaluation and they have
modeled this using statistical modeling
and also using mechanistic modeling so
these compartment based models that you
would might have heard of these sir
models which I know there's another
number file video of with with Ben
Sparks so go and check that one out so
yeah so they've used a combination of
these models and they've estimated that
around three million people a day are
probably getting newly infected with
with covid-19 each day so quite a large
number of people okay so that's three
million new a day but then but there are
people who already have it so right
exactly so there's three billion people
new a day and then we've got to think
about how many virus particles each of
these people has got and then we've got
to think about how long they're
infectious for so we need two things for
that we need to know what their Peak
viral load is so how many particles they
have when they're at their most
infectious and also we've got to know a
distribution for how infectious people
are so
um they'll start off not having very
many virus particles in their body but
then as the virus particles hijack their
cells and turn them into virus making
factories then they'll increase the
number of virus particles they have in
their body until the point where it
Peaks and that's the peak viral load and
then it'll start to decline as the body
starts to get on top of the virus so I
found a paper which estimates the peak
viral load in humans to be between 10 to
the 9 and 10 to the 11 particles so
that's a billion to 100 billion
particles for each person and the way
they did that is by looking at tissues
from monkeys so they looked at
respiratory and digestive tissue so
lungs and and your in the way that your
food gets through your body which is
where sarskoff 2 is most likely to be
and they calculated the concentrate or
the density of the number of particles
per unit mass of that tissue and so for
Respiratory tissues so things like the
lungs and the and the trachea they found
that they were between 10 to the 6 and
10 to the eight particles per gram so
that's between a million and 100 million
per gram and then they took those
estimates and they they worked them up
to see how much would be in a human and
so they thought well the the most
important tissue in human which is the
biggest contributor is going to be the
lungs and there's about a kilogram of
lung in the human apparently and so they
scaled that figure up from 10 to the six
per gram they scaled that up to 10 to
the 9 per kilogram if you like so on
average a human has between a billion
and 100 billion sarskov 2 particles at
Peak viral load in their body so now you
need to know this viral load
distribution right so I'll show you what
it looks like this is the viral load
Distribution on the y-axis and on the
x-axis this horizontal axis I've got
time looks something like this so you it
goes up like this it rises to a peak
around six days and then it falls off
quite slowly like that so this is this
is about six days here and so I guess
what we need to figure out who's
infected at any one time we need to
think about who got infected yesterday
and what their viral load distribution
is who got infected the day before and
what their viral load distribution is
and so on all the way up to the end of
this distribution so people that got
infected say yesterday
they will have a relatively low viral
load people who got infected
um the day before will have a slightly
higher viral load and so on until we get
to up to six days when we'll find that
people have their Peak viral load and
then people who got infected seven days
ago and eight days ago and nine days ago
and so on for the rest of this
distribution they'll have a lower viral
load and so we need to think about
technically mathematically what's called
a convolution so we need to be thinking
about how many people are infected two
days ago and multiply about that by how
high their viral load would be now how
many people were infected three days ago
and multiply that by what their viral
load would be now how many people
affected four days ago and so on so
that's technically called a convolution
it doesn't really matter how you think
of it but the point is that we have to
add up all these different viral loads
of people that got infected before today
thinking about how infectious they are
today and when you do that thinking
about three million people being
infected every day on average then you
can work out that there are 200
quadrillion virus particles in the world
so two with 17 zeros behind it so that's
roughly the same sort of order of
magnitude of the number of grains of
sand in the world it's probably about an
order of magnitude less but of course we
should carry out that by saying that
that number of grains of sand in the
world calculation is also a Fermi
estimate so it's not a sort of accurate
and and again so I'm more than happy for
people to to say that this is too high
or too low based on some different
estimates so for that uh calculation
there I used the the middle of the peak
distribution of the viral load so I used
uh instead of it's between a billion and
100 billion so I use 10 billion which
some someone will say well that's not
the average because if you add up a
billion and 100 billion and divide it by
two then that's about 50 billion but I'm
talking about a different oven talking
about the geometric average where you
multiply two numbers together and you
take their square root so that's that's
what I've used but of course in that
estimate there's two orders of magnitude
already so you could argue that it's ten
times bigger or ten times smaller
already but the in the middle of that
estimate is around 200 quadrillion virus
particles 200 quadrillion all the sand
on earth
sounds like a lot to me yeah it's a huge
number but then when we're thinking
about calculating the volume we've got
to remember that each of these virus
particles these SARS carve two particles
that cause covid-19 they're incredibly
small so again I looked up an estimate
for the the diameter of a source code 2
particle they're roughly spherical
that's what we'll assume they've got
these spikes sticking out of these Spike
proteins that you'll have heard of
um but the estimate is a round between
80 to 120 nanometers so in the middle
there is an estimate of 100 nanometers
so that's that's the estimate that we'll
use and once you know that estimate then
you can use relatively simple
mathematical formulas that people have
met at school probably so the formula
for the volume of a sphere is four
thirds times pi times the radius cubed
so the radius is half the diameter so
it's about 50 nanometers
and so when you you plug into that
formula you find that firstly sarskov 2
particles are incredibly small they take
up so little volume but of course there
are huge numbers of them and when you
multiply the number of virus particles
there's 200 quadrillion by the tiny
volume you get something which is which
is actually a tangible size it's about
120 milliliters and actually so that
could fit in about half a can of Coke
that's not quite the end of the story
though because
spheres we know don't pack together
nicely like cubes do or like bricks
stacking on the wall actually the way to
think about Spears is thinking about
when you go into a green grocery shop
thinking about a stack of oranges in a
pyramid maybe you think of those and you
think well not all of that is made up of
orange some of that is empty space so
actually the best you can do is packing
them like this pyramid of oranges to
pack spheres together and that only gets
you a volume of about 75 of that volume
of pyramid would actually be oranges and
25 of it would be empty space so I have
to account for that empty space when
we're putting these particles together
inside the can and that would probably
increase the the volume to about 160
milliliters so still enough to fit in
the kind of coke other people might
argue that
um you know you're never going to be
able to stack these spheres perfectly
and really you should be using random
close sphere packing and actually that's
that does even worse in terms of the
volume it's only about 60 there so if
you were to use that estimate it would
probably be about 200 mL liters of
sarskov 2 in total but still enough to
fit inside this can of Coke how many
milliliters on the counter so there's
330 in a can of Cokes it would be about
two-thirds full even at the upper end of
this estimate again I use that middle
estimate for the peak viral load even if
it were 10 times bigger then it would
probably be about two liters and then at
least it would be enough to fit in a two
liter Coke bottle if not a can of Coke
what about other stuff what about covert
that's not in humans it's like sitting
on surfaces and in the air and the
Animals yeah it's a it's a really good
point that not all covid is inside
humans
um so we think that covert doesn't last
very long on surfaces so I've
deliberately neglected that there are
animal reservoirs but again it's so hard
to quantify that um that I haven't put
that into the calculation but yes I've
just considered the covert that's inside
humans but certainly there's probably an
underestimate from that point of view
kit I'm assuming another thing you
didn't take into account with your
calculation is
how well these things do pack together
are there any repulsion forces involved
do those spikes cause problems yeah
absolutely so I haven't taken into
account any of the chemistry of the
problem uh and people have been asking
you know what would it be like if you
could get them all would it be a liquid
would it be solid I honestly don't know
I have spoken to a couple of chemists
about this but they also think it's
quite a hard thing to try and understand
but yeah certainly there would be
perhaps repulsive interactions between
these particles which might make it a
slightly bigger volume again but yeah I
haven't taken the chemistry it's more of
a physics and mathsy point of view this
one
nice I don't think Coco will thank us
for that no I know yeah I was really
mixed like when it when it went round
the world I was like uh maybe Coke will
be pleased because it's good exposure
but um probably they're going to be
disappointed with people thinking that
each kind of coke is full of SARS cough
two particles for the record that's not
the case no no absolutely 100 100 this
is I would you know I'll open this and
drink it right now